Now 52 000 people die every year from
sepsis that's a number a frightening
number but for those bereaved each is a
precious human being the bafta
award-winning actor Jason Watkins and
his wife Clara lost their daughter Maude
to sepsis she was two years old that was
12 years ago now they are campaigning to
raise awareness of sepsis and have a
documentary being aired tonight and
Jason and Clara are with me now and
first of all Clara just take us through
the beginning Maude had a respiratory
infection and you took it a hospital
twice yep what happened
so it was the week between Christmas and
New Year the the week of sort of where
you don't know what day it is and when
there's a sort of skeletal scar a star
for you know in the a e we took it to
the GP first who was said well it should
have really gone by now and uh she
advises just just for safety to go to a
e so we took it to a e and I had a
consultant there who said it's fine it's
croup and a chest infection she'll be
fine don't worry I was like are you sure
because the GP said it no no no no it's
fine so
um they sent me home with her with some
steroids and then the next day which was
the 31st of December uh her condition
worsened and she was having problems
breathing and it was really scary
because she really couldn't find her
breath and and we still thought oh this
is his chest infection is really bad so
we had to make a sort of Split Second
decision as to whether we should just
jump in our car and drive to the
hospital or call an ambulance we decided
to just jump in the car so we took her
to a e and Jason ran into a e with her
and yeah and I I ran I ran into triage
and you know said I need someone to see
my daughter and uh so I was seen I mean
probably in exactly the same spot where
you'd gone the previous day and was met
by the doctor on call and then later the
pediatrician on call and they said yes
it's croup and you know I was explaining
she was given gas and air and obviously
it was quite serious but um I don't
think they were really fully aware of
the kind of narrative of of what we'd
just been doing running through a
hospital with a child that would anyway
that calmed it down had more antibiotics
and it was given more steroids and then
her temperature began to fall and so she
was discharged again which is often the
case when they feel that a child would
be more comfortable at home so even
though my instincts were this is wrong
and weird I've got a I've got to go with
what the medical practitioners are
telling me so we took her home
and we put it in her cot and this is New
Year's Eve obviously we were going to go
out weren't we early on in the evening
um but uh we put her in lay on her court
and then in the morning
um Bessie came in or elder daughter
older daughter who shared a bedroom with
Morden said I can't wake mode so
we knew didn't we yeah I just
instinctively knew that something very
terrible had happened
I think also because she was always up
early and she wasn't up
um and your mind starts playing tricks
then everything goes you went in slow
motion yeah and I went into the room and
it was clear that she had died here
what I can't compute is what I read
about what you say about feeling
responsible for yourself for not knowing
that it was sepsis I mean doctors didn't
know that it was sepsis you are beating
yourself up over this yeah I mean in
fact I've just had a tweet
as well with somebody saying exactly the
same thing and I said to her straight
away it is not your fault
it isn't your fault it's so hard as a
parent to feel that it isn't you feel
that you're responsible for your child's
well-being being uh and it's a very
difficult one to shift it proves how
difficult and complex sepsis is for
parents to recognize the signs and for
medical practitioners
there are many things you've got to
adjust your life has changed forever
isn't it but doctors didn't really know
I mean clearly I mean we met when I was
an ambassador of a sepsis charity you
came along and it was my wife as a
doctor who told me to do this because
she said doctors didn't know enough
about it yeah and that people don't know
enough about it and so my question is
this documentary is that about getting
the message out
I mean it is very much so it's also very
much about loss child loss but it's also
about getting the message out about
awareness of sepsis that you know you
can as a parent you know so it's all on
the UK sepsis Trust website those signs
those vital signs of sepsis that occur
possibly behind presenting symptoms so
you may be thinking that the child is
pneumonia or chest infection and then
underneath there is lurking other things
where
you know the the brilliant immune system
the body can generate begins to turn
itself as a kind of as a negative force
and starts closing down organs and it's
very difficult to spot that so yeah yeah
but Clara doing it
you know with a documentary that
involves opening yourselves up in a very
raw way I imagine
um you know there's a moment in it where
you go through mords things
um how difficult was it to do that was
pretty that was difficult I'd say it was
probably one of the most difficult
things I've
done since
she died
um
and I didn't know whether I would
actually be able to go through all her
belongings until the sort of last
possible second they were there they
were in the room
um I'd never been particularly
sentimental about
things her stuff I very much was like
it's not her it's her stuff but because
they've been in storage at my friend's
house for 12 years they've taken on this
massive significance and so going
through her belongings
was it was
all these memories you know we kind of
opened the zip and it was like you know
I could smell her and
it's just the feel of it and it you just
remember it was really extraordinary and
it was it was not the most Pleasant
thing and afterwards I thought I
shouldn't have done that and then I
thought actually
it was good we took some things and we
gave the rest back to my friend and
she's put them back in her attic and I
sort of feel if we never have to do that
again it's okay it's interesting you say
that I just wonder where there's
something about this as well apart from
Raising awareness in which it's
cathartic in any way I mean yeah we kind
of been wrestling with that I know and
you want it to be of course you wanted
to be a kind of catharsis that you've
examined and gone back and just it's
really hard to make yeah you know every
time we have the therapies if we've been
to a
when we used to go to slow and stuff and
we thought about mud it always brought
us together so it was it's exhausting
emotionally and this was this was times
10 wasn't it it was very hard so it did
bring us together but in terms of
catharsis I think you need to think
clearly and have help in the way that
you think to get through these things so
you said earlier on something quite
interesting it's also about child loss
as well as about sepsis is there still a
taboo do you think about
losing a child and talking about it and
bearing with it I mean yes and I I mean
it's almost like mental illness isn't it
that people are very scared to talk
about it because they're scared that
might happen to them or that people in
their family are affected by it and
child bereavement is it's such a taboo
subject how do I talk to somebody who's
lost a child it must be so difficult
they must be feeling desperate or you
know I don't want to talk to them about
that because I don't want to have to
think about it don't entertain the fact
that my own child might die so there
becomes a bit of a Schism between but
also I think people don't want to talk
about it to us certainly now so many
years on because they think I don't want
to remind them I don't they look like
they're having a nice day
I don't want to mention Maude because
they might feel sad and I think you know
most bereaved parents that I've have
spoken to and now work with
um they love when people talk about
their child even if their child died 20
years before
it's joyful to hear their child's name
and to know that they're still thought
of thought about and I think we feel the
same we love it when people talk about
more they because it's sort of that's
what keeps her alive yeah and so not
only not only talking about you know
talking about talking about it you're
looking at it that way I've taken over
it we've been talking a lot about
Preston trying to find a way
talking about it and I often stamp on
your toes don't so I apologize for that
but I mean you know could you tell that
I was looking at you like yeah you had
that look I mean that's one of the great
things that we discovered how close we
are isn't it
that we understand each other we've been
on this journey together and it's so
wonderful to have Clara in this here now
having talked a lot on my own about it
particularly sepsis well look you're
doing it a very important thing do you
think more people do know about sepsis
now I think they do and I know that for
example you know there are some
yesterday I think I saw some uh some
signage going up on ambulances they do
know about it and but they can you can
always investigate more there are 13 000
we think preventable deaths so a
preventable death is a death that might
should not have happened out of that
number that you quoted people think
about steps yeah and it's a very
printable isn't it if it's called if
it's called and you can see on the
website except that people want to see
that you know yeah those signs are there
so look we've only got a minute or so
left but I just wanted to ask you
finally
you know we talk about more we don't
know what she was like what was she like
what are your memories of her what sort
of little girl was she well
I would just say that it's been
difficult this week but she's very much
been present and when we had a screening
the other night in a cinema we had
friends and people helping to point
people towards the transmission on
Thursday to see her on the big screen
those little videos that we took on our
phones to see how that size really did
it was very emotional but really brought
her back and that was wonderful she was
very she was a really happy child she
was an easy all I think it's very easy
to kind of make make her a sort of
you know perfect being because she's not
here to do anything wrong but actually
she really does she really was a very
happy joyful sweet natured
lovely child who laughed all the time
and um
she was just joyous really listen
um thank you very much for coming in
you're doing a very good thing
um a lot of respect for that good luck
with the program and thank you thank you
thank you very much for coming here
thank you